ANTHONY HOPKINS, WHO'S DONE
PRETTY DAMN WELL FOR HIMSELF,
ESPECIALLY THIS YEAR, SAID, "THE
MINUTE I PUT ON THE WARDROBE,
THE CHARACTER JUST UNFOLDS.”
"EMMA'S" ALEXANDRA BYRNE HAD THE
CHALLENGE OF DESIGNING COSTUMES
FOR A FILM SET IN THE EARLY
19TH CENTURY.
TO MEET THAT CHALLENGE SHE
LOOKED AT EVERYTHING.
PAINTINGS, JOURNALS, AND
EVEN IN MUSEUMS.
TO PREPARE FOR "MA RAINEY'S
BLACK BOTTOM," COSTUME DESIGNER
ANN ROTH READS THE SCRIPT, AND
ASKS HERSELF QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
CHARACTER LIKE, "WHEN SHE GOES TO
BED, WHERE ARE THOSE CLOTHES?
DO THEY FALL ON THE FLOOR?
DOES SHE HANG THEM UP?"
FROM THERE, ANN BUILDS THE
COSTUMES WHICH DEFINE THE CHARACTER.
FOR "MANK," TRISH SUMMERVILLE
USED SEARS AND ROEBUCK
CATALOGUES, CHARLIE CHAPLIN
MOVIES, AND STILL PHOTOGRAPHS
FROM THE '20S, '30S AND '40S TO
CREATE AN AUTHENTIC LOOK OF REAL
PEOPLE FROM MOVIE HISTORY.
BINA DAIGELER SPENT THREE WEEKS
IN CHINA RESEARCHING COSTUMES
FOR "MULAN."
SHE SAID HER GOAL WAS TO ENABLE
THE AUDIENCE TO GRASP SOMETHING
ESSENTIAL ABOUT THE CHARACTER.
AND IN THE CASE OF "MULAN"
HERSELF, SHE USED COLOR AND
COSTUME TO CONVEY AN UPLIFTING
AND POSITIVE MESSAGE.
"PINOCCHIO'S" COSTUME DESIGNER
MASSIMO CANTINI PARRINI ALSO IS
A STRONG BELIEVER THAT COLOR
HELPS CREATE THE CHARACTER.
AND BECAUSE RED IS THE COLOR
THAT EXPRESSES POWERFUL EMOTIONS
LIKE ANGER, PASSION, LOVE, AND
LYING, "PINOCCHIO" BECAME THE
ONLY CHARACTER IN
THE MOVIE WEARING RED.
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
ANN ROTH,
"MA RAINEY'S BLACK BOTTOM."
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE ACADEMY
CONGRATULATES ANN ROTH
AND ACCEPTS THE OSCAR
ON HER BEHALF.
THANK YOU.